vous ne le saviez peut-être pas mais le
4 octobre est désormais la Journée
mondiale des animaux et oui à cette
occasion nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de sopian terf lui passe des
journées entières adresser ses bergers
allemands pour le cinéma ses compagnons
à quatre pattes élevés près de Château
La Valière sont actuellement à l'affiche
de dogman le dernier film de Luc Besson
alors comment ont-ils vécu ses jours de
tournage en studio la réponse dans ce
reportage de Lucas
Chopin allez
pas bouger ces chiens sont de véritables
stars les animaux de sopian crèvent
l'écran dans des films tels que sœur de
Yamina bengigi ù les séries canal plus
66.5 et Paris police 1905 mais la
dernière fierté de ce comportementaliste
canin est actuellement à l'écran 6 de
ces bêtes apparaissent dans dogman le
nouveau thriller signé Luc Besson c'est
extraordinaire quoi c'est quelqu'un qui
était très à l'écoute qui me laissait le
temps de préparer mes actions comme il
fallait et c'était super quoi c'était
pas l'acteur qui se faisait m c'était
moi qui doublait l'acteur et qui qui
faisait qui a réalisait les cascades
notamment la cascade qu'on peut voir
dans la bande annonce la cascade du du
pendu quoi parmi les comédiennes le
berger allemand
[Musique]
Lili nous avons profité de sa présence
pour nous aussi nous glisser dans la
peau du personnage de dogman attaque
[Musique]
le bonheur de ces chiens est primordial
pour sopiane dans son élevage les
animaux sont quasiment en liberté et voi
le dressage comme de l'amusement c'est
un travail quotidien où d'abord d'abord
avant de avant d'avoir des actions de
cinéma tout ça il y a une base des s'il
est né chez moi à partir de 2 mois on
commence si c'est un chien que j'ai
récupéré bah du coup on remet les la
base d'éducation on est sur du jeu le
chien ne MT pas l'humain en soi il mort
la combinaison que l'humain va porter
outre pour le grand écran sopian dresse
des chiens policiers militaires ou
pompiers il élève aussi des animaux
parfaits pour la vie en
famille